e
okay being 10:00 we'll open the work
session on House
362 and somebody here talk about it oh
okay
um we don't need to introduce it really
no does anybody have any any uh comments
for or against uh House Bill 362 because
the fiscal note has no costs indicated I
mean I kind of like I don't know why
it
well
representative well thank you Mr chair I
was gonna say the same thing that I have
no idea why this came to finan see how
all the work seems to be something that
most likely can be covered with the
existing budget and the existing U you
know Staffing and uh Frank
ly it seems rather non-controversial you
know let's look into issues and have a
report examining certain things I just
don't think we'll have a lot of
discussion around it you know I don't
want to make a motion right now but I'm
ready to make a motion
anytime well well suggest a
motion without further dialogue I
entertain a motion so you'd like to move
it I'd like to recommend that we
recommend OTP to the full finance
committee okay do you have a second
second okay all those in favor or do we
need to take a roll call we can just
raise your hand all those in favor
y oppos okaye
unanimous so we're now on a Hiatus until
10:20 enjoy yourself well that will give
me a 30 seconds to take the
notes I would I would mention to the the
committee one other thing we've got a
concurrence from the from from the
Senate
just let me ask you uh we've been asked
to concur with with our house bill uh
468 which was the one about the $100,000
to rectify part of
educational rsas and stuff what the
Senate has done is is they have included
that but they've also set up a a
committee or a commission to work with
this independent attorney I I think it's
an excellent idea so I will tell Ken
recommend
yep and this well this actually expands
I think it's a good
expansion yeah okay yeah if you remember
I don't know if he was in education we
no I don't think he was there but we
that we discussed that in Ed on the
education commit disc years right right
and we figured it would take six years
time well they they they they're more
specific in their language because they
talk about uh duplicative and contrary
and those kind of words so uh I think
they did a nice job I haven't taken a
look at the um makeup of the commission
do you do you recall what
the component
was uh one member of the Senate two
members of the House the commissioner of
Education or designity director of
legislative
Services Vision
panel and then it has a school board
member appointed by the New Hampshire
School Board of teacher appointed by the
commission of Education a school
administrator a representative of the
Board of Education representative of the
National Education Association any
additional individual organization the
commission deems relevant to its study
and recodification process so it's
pretty
expansive okay well now we're on a
highest
until
e
okay being 10:20 uh open the work
217 having to do with underserved Area
Educator incentive program would anybody
like to make any comments one way or the
line oh thank you thank you for uh
allowing me to speak uh Mr chairman
Brian Hawkins for the record uh
representing Nea New Hampshire um this
bill took a long journey to get here U
so it was retained as you Pro probably
have seen in the record in the Senate
originally uh the bill came to the house
uh or or was began as uh a similar
program to what they have in the state
of Idaho which was uh began a couple of
years ago because like us they have a
teacher shortage uh particularly in
certain school districts and the idea
was to uh help reduce barriers for uh
those who wanted to enter the Prof
profession and I think that's really the
goal of the bill and what Senator Fenton
uh who is a prime sponsor um uh intended
to do uh there was the legislature
established a teacher shortage committee
a couple of years ago that took uh a
two-year period of time to look at what
are the reasons that we're experiencing
a Workforce
shortage uh they also issued a series of
recommendations on what would be helpful
uh to help alleviate viate that and one
of the recommendations was um a rural
and underserved uh educator incentive
program that would help Educators in
their first years um when they've you
know racked up a nice amount of debt
having had the pleasure of both doing
student teaching and paying the college
that they went to to do that student
teaching um and in those first years
where in New Hampshire the starting
salary uh for teachers is uh you know
significantly lower than
Massachusetts um and our New England
partners and so uh the idea was Let's uh
have a graduate this graduated increase
to not only uh help the educator would
also incentivize them to stay in that
particular School District because one
of the things that we know is that
the longer you get over those initial
few years of being a teacher um some of
the hardest um Parts uh period of time
in your career the more likely uh uh you
are to stay so um the house did change
this uh a bit so that it it um at least
as we read it it rather than being a
loan repayment it is more of a a
incentive retention payment um and uh
but it as I said we are in a teacher
shortage um
and school districts particularly those
that you know struggle to have higher
starting salary salaries higher average
salaries um you know this is added help
uh uh for those districts and for those
students which which is ultimately the
most important thing that we have
qualified you know teachers um who
[Music]
are there and hopefully beginning a long
career in teaching so um happy to try
and answer any other questions you may
have um representative he oh thank you I
think this is a great idea um I know
when I was Deputy Commissioner um trying
to figure out ways to get those teachers
into the areas where we need them the
most now it sounds like from my read of
the bill that there's going to be a
commission that's going to kind of
oversee it is there any problem um with
teacher contracts with these um stiens
that we're going to be giving people
because they'll come through the
department of Ed I assume so the um the
the commission specifically referenced
in here is the higher education
commission and they would be doing the
rule making uh here uh this so in the
budget uh you may recall in hb2 to there
was
a uh not somewhat similar incentive
program around the computer science uh
and so um you know this is being R this
is not something that is that
relationship between the employee and
the employer this is a sort of targeted
Aid that's coming directly from the
state so I don't think that would be an
issue uh we have had numerous
conversations with the Department around
this issue
um and the need for that um and so uh we
would be eager to work with the
Department of Education to help them in
the the crafting of rules and process
for application so if I may and this is
specific to Public Schools yes uh rural
poor areas yes um and I should add uh
since we're in the finance committee we
W I would love to put a plugin for the
next budget to go from $1 to a a higher
amount of money um I think that's the
intention and Senator Bradley and in the
Senate finance committee when they did
make this change to a dollar indicated
that that was sort of his hope that um
they could you know have the policy in
place and then you know explore the
finances in the subsequent budget good
thank you just one final question so
this bill would um authorize
this group to get together and set out
and lay out the plans how it's going to
be distributed so we'll be all ready to
go into the next budget process I think
so I think so I think um as I mentioned
earlier uh the original model for this
bill was the state of Idaho and the
program that they passed there you know
they uh so there still are a lot of
similarities there um but their
Department of Education established a a
rubric to as the bill indicates to sort
of live within the appropriation that
they have uh to to be a and to be able
to score
applications um so that they could as I
said live within the uh resources
established by the the uh the
legislature uh the uh this
is not too dissimilar as well from a
rural healthc care um program for uh
healthcare workers that was uh
established by the department ofth
Health and Human Services um so uh I
think it gives the opportunity to put
the the finer points in place the
process so that's clear for uh people
who would apply um and hopefully as I
said go go go up from a dollar in the
appropriation represent
Miller thank you Mr chair um two
questions one what are the other
barriers um presented to teachers um
that would prevent them from staying and
secondly can you describe the typical
teacher who would have this uh male
female married not married with Children
without children sure um I'll do my best
to to answer what I can um so
uh sorry your fir your first if you
other barriers other barriers um so
actually the the teacher shortage report
that um was a House and Senate committee
did look at the barriers and issue uh a
series of findings not all of them are
Financial
um there is the individ the culture of
an individual school you know who's your
principal and how is that run um and
also the overall the challenges in
overall climate uh uh generally
politically
um and so the shortage report goes
through all of that um and I'd be happy
to provide the uh division a copy of
that I think it's worth a read and um
and this isn't the only uh suggestion
that they made as a um as a
recommendation so um not all of them are
are necessarily you know have a fiscal
component to them but um uh some of them
do mentorship
programs um you know that help in the
early years when you're um uh sort of
going to sink or swim as uh in the
profession
so I oh I just had a quick
question
yeah um you know a description of who
most likely will benefit from this or
who are the teachers that are coming in
says gender age children not children
status sure um I uh I could get back to
you on the the in sort of incoming class
of Educators uh you know it is overall
uh you know more much more um female for
sure um and uh the I think one of the
changes that we've experienced is the
pathways so we don't just have the sort
of classic teacher prep you know I
wanted to be a teacher since I was my
daughter wants to be a teacher she's
nine you know um there are certainly
those out there but uh there's also been
the increase of uh teaching as a sec as
a second profession and so we've seen an
increase in licenses through the site
based
licenses um the these are you know
largely the the second career folks who
um are have a plan in place uh to get
them to
certification uh feedback through their
uh initial years um on the um on the job
and um we've seen
uh a an exponential growth in those
well thank you Mr chair just I I don't
know if the question is for you know
Brian or for anybody else I just want to
make sure I understand correctly the
language in uh Roman numeral 7 the way I
read it if a teacher stays through the
four years they will receive payments
adding up to
12,000 I just want to make sure I
understand it correctly because when I
see total incentive award that wording
may be a bit vague so do I read it
correctly that they will receive each of
those four payments adding up to 12,000
if they stay for the first four years
through four years yeah through the four
four that's H yeah thank
you each year yeah in the amount so the
four amounts add to each other and if
they make it through the full four years
then they will add up to the
you yes uh thank you again can you say a
little bit more about the licensing when
you talked about people coming in as a
second career um I'm aware of people who
would like to teach in a public school
um but licensing is a problem and um as
an aside I hear you know there's some
discussion about lowering licensing
requirements which I do not support but
if you have someone with life experience
and would like to teach a course in
their area of expertise they can't um
what I'm hearing is that they're told oh
you could form a club and is there some
you know potential for taking advantage
of people in the community with a
particular expertise who could at in
their Advanced years become a science
teacher or a literature
teacher uh so there there are a number
of Pathways that you can take for
someone who would fit in that category
so there uh I don't profess to be an
expert on the all the uh alternative
uh no those are th those are there and
then also you know for those districts
that um there's Al there there's also
like an emergency authorization that um
is time limited you know
I think I I know of some people who fit
sort of some of the categories that you
were talking about um but hopefully part
of the reason that is time limited is so
that if if that person
says I want I want to continue to do
this it's important that they find one
of those alternative Pathways with the
uh um you know the school administration
so that they can receive feedback on
what it is is they're doing well what it
is they need to work on and the sort the
pedagogy of of of teaching kids so um
what were the programs you mentioned I
did all four all
three what I don't even I still didn't
hear
you there on the Department of Education
website it lists a number of alternative
Pathways to becoming a teacher
alternative three is you produce a
portfolio and you sit before a panel of
individuals
all four you are given a preliminary um
license and you're assigned a mentor and
you have a form of various things that
you have to have documented that you
have achieved but over the years we've
seen more and more um older people
coming in to teach as second careers
especially in the areas of mathematics
and science um because it's very
fulfilling and um coming out of business
they've made their money and they want
to give back to their community and they
so there are those alternative Pathways
as long as they haven't changed um the
alternative four is one that we
use frequently for special education as
an assistant superintendent I had to use
that often because it was so hard to
find special ed teachers same thing with
math and science but um there are
Pathways you need you do need a college
degree and you need a certain number of
uh credit hours in in the certain area I
don't know how they look at um
experience now that that might be
something that might have changed but um
I forget the um name of the band at the
department now uh uh Steve Apple um he's
he I you would call him and he could
tell you all this I don't suggest it as
a solution but as an option absolutely
and a par professionals too we're seeing
more
par par professionals um
going finishing college and then going
on to become
teachers
comments thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you for taking my question now over the
last 10 years we've seen an 80% increase
in
administrators all right now we spend
about $20,000 per student average class
size is 12 that's
$240,000 right I mean to do the
math it seems so we're re allocating our
direction would you comment on it is
that well um so uh I think new H New
Hampshire has
um started out in a place where I think
there was not the necessary supports to
begin with in schools and we we know
that we one of the reasons that we lag
in this Workforce area is that we don't
pay teachers enough and so um you know
and you all know that school funding
plays a huge role in that and as so the
when we see uh you know increases in Aid
uh a lot of that Aid is has to go
directly into you know catching people
up and uh school districts competing
with each other
to try and um poach other you know
teachers to uh come across to a school
district that you know going from a a
Newport to a Handover for example um so
I think
that we have uh we and we also have you
know a series of other uh crises that
we're facing mental health drug
addiction that's impacting students um
and I think that schools haven't had the
support that they've needed and um
so uh I think that we need to do more to
help those students um I don't think
that we've been doing enough and so
probably coming at it from a slightly
different perspective but I think
there's more that we can do and um and I
hope that uh you know the legislature
will continue to look at this as we go
into the next budget and talk about what
additional supports we can uh help from
the state level to also help you know
well any other questions or comments and
thank you for taking the grilling oh
happy well I didn't want you to have no
one in the audience to well we did the
previous
B yeah happy to come back if you need me
to talk about something else okay thank
you okay any other
comments yes representative uh no
comments Mr chair but if you're ready
for a motion I be happy to move um a to
pass for Senate Bill 27 FNA okay second
sure all
right all those in
favor I'm GNA vote
against well show a hands for all in
favor just so you can you I mean yeah
but you keep keeping track because we
don't we're not unanimous all right
although those
two so we will recommend to full Finance
217 Mickey you have anything else to
beard but I I do I I do think we have
some challenges as full
Finance because the amount of money that
we've have been voted and still pending
to be voted uh it's a lot of money did
you all get a copy of that
uh LBA yeah Mike Kane sent that out yeah
okay it's good but trouble is we don't
have the money I know okay if there's
nothing else I'm not sure when we'll
meet again but I'm sure we will
soon Thursday then I guess Thursday yeah
yep so enjoy the nice day cuz rain is on
the way hey watch your
mouth I watch the news this morning I I
didn't but my wife tells me what the
weather is she wrong about
time well they said rain Wednesday and
Thursday who
knows no the reason I voted against it
is
because